- [Ari] If you're thinking
of a wild mushroom,
you're probably thinking of death
and poisoning and vomiting.
- [Jenna] But, now that
I'm a mushroom hunter,
I think wonder.
- [Ari] Opportunity.
- [Jenna] Delicacy.
- [Ari] Potential.
- [Woman] Beauty.
- [Man] Every corner in the forest
has a new surprise in the
mycological world behind it.
My name is Ari Rockland-Miller.
- [Woman] And I'm Jenna Antonino DiMare.
- [Ari] And we are mycophiles.
- [Jenna] AKA, mushroom lovers.
(easygoing instrumental music)
- In the United States
alone, there are at least
40 or 50 gourmet edible wild mushrooms,
and those run the gamut
from the chanterelle
with a powerful apricot aroma,
to the black trumpet with
an earthy fig-like flavor
to hen of the woods, which
looks like a hen roosting
at the base of an oak tree in the fall.
There's an unbelievable diversity.
When I was a little kid,
I would just pile up
every mushroom I could find
in the woods around my house.
That was the beginning of the journey.
I do have dreams about wild mushrooms,
and then I sort of wake up.
And the first thing I want
to do the next morning
is get out for mushrooms.
(lively instrumental music)
Often, I'm moving fast,
looking for brightly colored mushrooms.
Other times, I'm really getting
down on my hands and knees
crawling around the moss
at the base of a beech tree
looking for a black trumpet.
- Ari can become extremely enthusiastic
about hunting for mushrooms.
And there have been times in the past
where he'll be out for
hours and hours and hours
at a time but won't
come back with anything.
- Finding them does take time,
but every now and then, all
of a sudden, you see one.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And that is the most powerful reverie,
unbelievable rush every time.
We use our knife and our mushroom brush,
and fill up our basket.
- [Jenna] We don't over-harvest mushrooms.
There isn't a monetary incentive.
- [Ari] We do want to
leave some in the ground
to spread their spores and to reproduce.
The hunt is intrinsically satisfying.
It's an epic treasure hunt.
It reconnects me to a
childhood sense of wonder.
On a good day, we can bring home
many pounds of wild mushrooms.
- [Jenna] When we bring
our mushrooms back,
it's always such a joy to look
through our find from the day
and cook them up that evening.
(easygoing instrumental music)
We don't resell the mushrooms
that we find in the forest.
We instead enjoy them ourselves.
We pick just enough to share
with our family and friends.
- [Ari] Mushrooms have taught me
that even in the tiniest things,
there's so much potential
that there are whole worlds
that we ignore that
contain so much flavor,
beauty, mystery, wonder.